even after three inconclusive elections
and being charged in three corruption
cases Benjamin Netanyahu has shown once
again that he's going nowhere with hours
of great responsibility Binney Kent and
I decided to form a unity government and
avoid a further election the division
and distrust remain evident in this
unity deal Netanyahu and his former
rival Benny Ganz have written into it
all kinds of guards against betrayal
sworn in simultaneously as Prime
Minister and alternate Netanyahu to go
first then Gantz after 18 months an
unprecedented 36 ministries shared
equally
we decided to take national
responsibility especially at this time
Israel needs a national government that
represents broad sections of the country
after more than ten years the era of
government by one half of the nation is
over we are here to represent those who
felt they had no voice in leading this
country but Ganz also predicted bitter
arguments to come one big difference
their position on annexing 30% of the
occupied West Bank under the terms of
the Trump peace plan Gantz is calling
for delay and consultation Netanyahu is
doubling down it is time to apply
Israeli law and rise a glorious chapter
in the history of Zionism this step
doesn't delay peace it brings it closer
because peace must be based on the truth
and the truth is that there are hundreds
of thousands of settlers and Judea and
Samaria under the coalition deal
Netanyahu can bring annexation for a
vote any time after July the first Gantz
has no veto power but the terms of the
deal say that annexation has to be
carried out in coordination with the US
and must not threaten any regional peace
treaties so now the u.s. seems to be
signaling that it wants to see a delay
and Jordan's King says annexation would
cause massive conflict with Israel
Netanyahu and Ganz say their new
government answers the call of the
Israeli people at a time of pandemic and
economic crisis ganses former opposition
ally says it serves the interests of
politicians not voters look at how this
government was established zero trust
between the partners
everything through lawyers and court
debates overriding the basic laws people
who don't believe a word the other says
maybe it is at least for now a
functioning government the first Israel
has had a nearly 18 months but its
structure is unprecedented and faces
severe tests over the impact of the
coronavirus annexation and having a
prime minister whose corruption trial is
due to start next Sunday
Harry Fawcett al Jazeera West Jerusalem
Ali Abunimah is the co-founder of
Electronic Intifada an independent
online news publication focusing on
Palestine he doesn't expect any change
in policy toward Palestinians from the
new government it's not as if any
Israeli government would have presented
Palestinians with somehow a peaceful way
out of Israeli occupation apartheid
every Israeli government has been
implacably hostile to Palestinian rights
including this one which is headed by
the two authors of among many other
things the 2014 assault on Gaza during
which Israel killed one in every 1000
residents of the occupied Gaza Strip
Netanyahu is of course Prime Minister
then and Gantz was the army chief so
these are two people who despite
whatever personal animosity they have
are an ideological lockstep in terms of
completing the colonization of the West
Bank and if they have any disagreements
it's very minor tactical disagreements
about how not upset
the so-called international community
too much but there's they really don't
have anything to worry about because
we've seen that the United States the
European Union many Arab regimes
including especially the Gulf regimes
are very much on board with this Israeli
government so Israel doesn't think it
has too much to worry about